give us a piece of your baggage and  we'll leave it right here cheating  great okay Paulie there's been lots of  allegations of you cheating mm-hmm is  that true  it is untrue okay I really want to  believe that so I want to stop you right  there so what does it mean to you if it  is true I mean if it's you're out I know  why wouldn't you leave it but doesn't I  just again on the comprehend that I  really ship is a roller coaster we're on  we're off Ron we're off the real truth  is I've I've never cheated but it's a  bunch of bull you should be able to be  stronger than that if you really believe  in why the hell do you stay because do  you want to be with me or not just  answer that Wow that's it Wow  [Music]  you  [Music]